hugh jackman talks about why he turned
down cats
uh no hugh jackman talks as if hugh
jackman talks if he'll return as
wolverine for Hulk vs. Wolverine movie
that sounds better that sounds a lot
better than see cats this week's the
butthole cut of the Wolverine movie yes
and Justice League and cat we're gonna
watch from the CW
I mean cosmic wander oh ah how's it
going everybody it's Warren welcome back
to my channel the cosmic wonder where we
talk about all things related to Marvel
and of course the MCU we have had some
major news just recently be dropped
yesterday and today Mark Ruffalo talks
about returning as the Hulk not only
returning for a TV series she-hulk
but also whether or not he's going to
return for his own movie or team-up film
and what that film could be about not to
mention that Taika Waititi has recently
teased that Hulk could show up and Thor
love and thunder and also Mark Ruffalo
mentioned in a Hulk vs. Wolverine film
and to top it all off we have Hugh
Jackman talking about whether or not he
is actually considering coming back to
Mars safe play Wolverine
so we'll first start I avoided the news
so I could react to this video in where
he talked about the Hulk and then go
into the Hugh Jackman interview talking
about Wolverine if you're new be sure to
subscribe and notifications turn so
postman 5:51 k1 or a ps4 at five hundred
and fifty thousand subscribers smokeless
so this first interview is with Mark
Ruffalo and a variety and it's the
interview where he drops another Hulk
vs. Wolverine bomb now of course
everybody wants Mark Ruffalo to return
to play The Hulk not everybody was
completely satisfied with his story arc
and Avengers in game
and I think it was done as read by
variety mark ruffalo wants to return to
play the character as well now we've
heard Mark Ruffalo kind of talk about
him returning to the MC and we've heard
him say that he's had meetings with
Kevin Feige to talk about the future of
the Hulk and see what it would be like
the end of this when saying that he
would like to return he also added
there's nothing completely at a place
where it's a done deal
there's some talk of having banner slash
the Hulk show up in the Disney Plus
Series she-hulk if we come up with
something good that would be really
interesting right now that's about it
that's all there is on the table however
he then went on to talk about a stand
alone Hulk film and what he would like
to see if that happened and he said
there's an idea that I think could be
really interesting we never really
followed him into his life he's always
kind of off on the side he's like at the
Rosencrantz and the Guildenstern of the
Avengers it would be interesting to fill
in all the blanks about what happened to
him in between all these movies which is
kind of what they did in Thor Ragnarok
at the end of Avengers level that's what
you know what's an entire solo Hulk film
dedicated to what he's done but of
course before the end watch again went
on to say that I would love to see a
halt verse Wolverine film and he
explained why the interview explains
that Mark Ruffalo grew up reading comics
but specifically Marvel Comics x-men and
Wolverine yessir says that Disney's
Marvel has purchased a box and with it
the rights to the x-men characters and
films and Wolverine maybe Hulk and
Wolverine because I always remind you
this is the fourth time that Mark
Ruffalo has ezzat a Hulk versa well
Vereen film is what he was what I've
always wanted
fishel interview with a major media
outlet he 100% knows that people are
going to hear about this he 100% knows
that people
like me and going to make videos on it
but you enjoy those tacos boring so it
seems like something is definitely going
on here and not to mention we've had
previous several months ago stating that
there is a Hulk vs. Wolverine really may
talked about some of you may recall that
a Hulk vs. Wolverine film was talked
about last year in September community
scooper Mikey Sutton mentioned on his
Facebook group that a Hulk vs. Wolverine
film was being talked about at marvel
studios and now many many months later
Mark Ruffalo in an interview has
expressed interest in a Wolverine versus
the Hulk solo film for the 4th time so
clearly something is going on over at
Marvel Studios even if it's just being
talked about for the current moment but
the real question is Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine if we're having a Wolverine
versus the Hulk film who is going to be
the Wolverine Hugh Jackman beat every
brain storm sentence originally guesses
that there's I'm going to recast a brain
it will not be Hugh Jackman and he also
said that it's probably several years
away well now we have an official answer
from Hugh Jackman himself in an
interview the other day with The Daily
Beast Hugh Jackman opened up a lot he
talked a lot about his upcoming film bad
education and then of course he was
asked about Wolverine he talked about
how this year in June is going to be 20
years since his debut as Wolverine film
and then of course in the interview they
had to ask if he was returning and they
said you were great as Wolverine
particularly in Logan which was such a
nice Cota to the character now that
Disney and Fox are merged it does seem
like there are a lot of pasta videos
gonna anyway saying we're now expelling
in ways that it couldn't look the way
that cameo he replied tastes totally a
pest
honestly Marla if for seven years ago
that had happened I'd be like oh yeah
but I knew it was the right time for me
to leave the party not just for me but
for the character somebody else will
pick it up and run with it it's too good
of a character not to it's kind of like
you're on your way home and your friend
rings you and goes oh dude a new DJ just
came on and the music is awesome are you
going to come back
you say sounds good but no they're fine
with someone else so straight from your
mouth of Hugh Jackman himself he is done
with Wolverine and he even has mentioned
before that Logan was the perfect
CIND off and his goodbyes to the
character Wolverine
now it is also important to note that
Patrick Stewart also said the same exact
thing but he has recently met with
Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige to
talk about Charles Xavier in the MCU now
it seems kind of clear that Patrick
Stewart is done but perhaps he could be
brought on board to consult for the new
Professor Xavier that is coming on
because clearly Kevin Feige talked to
him about plans Patrick Stewart said it
himself and if he's not returning what
she stated what else could he be doing
meeting with Kevin Feige he's giving
advice on the characters guns hoping
Kevin Feige with the direction and it
does seem like Professor Xavier is going
to be headed to the MCU before Wolverine
does but when that time comes when
Wolverine enters the MCU they will most
likely speak to Hugh Jackman about to
character about the direction they want
to go about the stories they want about
what that he was he's got a Wolverine
we all loved him and it's hard to
imagine anybody else's mess very much
now and I think that they can tell the
actor as it goes and this had happened
Disney or Fox he would have loved to do
it he would have loved to play Wolverine
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe 7 years
ago not even like a full 10 years but
only 7 years ago and he would have done
it we missed him just barely but
hopefully he does come back and consult
with Marvel Studios about what to do
with the next Wolverine that's going to
enter the MCU but this does leave us
with the question of if we do get a Hulk
vs. Wolverine movie who was going to
play Wolverine which of course we can't
answer right now there's no way of
knowing and what direction are they
going to take the Hulk well according to
the same report that Mikey stated way
back last year in September we're going
to get some version of immortal Hulk now
all of you who are not aware of who
immortal Hulk is it's a very very
different version of the Hulk Professor
Hulk that we saw as in-game immortal
pile of grass or
there is immortal hope is brutal and he
even punches holes through planets but
there's also a very big psychological
and emotional component to immortal Hulk
and if we think about with the Hulk but
again if Marvel Studios does go ahead
and decide to actually make Wolverine a
versus Hulk film it will probably be a
few years away which means that we will
probably see the hope show up before
then and as Mark Ruffalo mentioned in
the interview there are plans right now
nothing concrete but our plans for him
to appear and she hope and it makes
perfect sense because we just got the
official synopsis for she-hulk and it
reads following an injury Jennifer
Walters receives an emergency blood
transfer make it happen off-camera in
Bruce Banner holding and thinking we're
like great shots horribly showgirl
actually fill our dreams here while
still largely retaining her personality
in particular she retains her
intelligence and emotional control
although like Hulk she still becomes
stronger if enraged and it's also been
revealed that shooting for the she-hulk
at Disney Plus that is about to starting
what why and will be heard for a while
carriers in the characters or she-hulk
is going to become the Hulk and get her
condition from her cousin who was Bruce
Banner we all assumed that they're going
to show some type of origin story for
her how she becomes the hope so it would
just make perfect sense that they would
have Mark Ruffalo as Bruce Banner in the
show now we probably won't get that much
hulking out from him he'll probably just
step in the save the day but he'll still
be Professor Hulk unless he somehow
manages to separate himself again which
I don't think is going to happen so it
seems like the first time that we're
going to see the Hulk return to the MCU
is going to be she-hulk but the great
news is that it does seem like Mark
Ruffalo really wants a Hulk vs.
Wolverine film and he's talked about it
enough to make us believe that he's
definitely talked to Kevin Feige about
it and Marvel Studios is definitely
mulling it over and even if we don't get
Hugh Jackman returning as well
which it looks like we're not going to
it will still be awesome to see a Hulk
vs Wolverine film but let me know what
you think about this in the comments
down below I got I would like to play
Wolverine I got dizzy Jackman back now
so who's your second pick let me know in
the comments down below and don't forget
to like this video and subscribe when
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on all things happening in
the MCU for live updates you can follow
me on Twitter and I get a lot more so
much for watching
woof woof thinking about tomorrow's
dinner cuz it's Saturday
oh yeah thinking about Sunday brunch
whoa
I usually just plan my meals in advance
all the snacks - it's a good video
thanks Warren
let's go get food so Hugh Jackman's
definitely returning that's what I got
from this video and Mark Ruffalo's out
is Hulk so we're gonna get a video every
time Hugh Jackman is asked a question
about Wolverine that's how print
websites do it literally every time
there's an interview with him about
Wolverine someone's got a report on it
the title of the video and all fairness
is Hugh Jackman talks if he'll return as
Wolverine and he did talk about David he
would and he talked in depth he did he
compared it to a DJ getting a phone call
wow there's a whole other set of music
on but I guess I don't like music
anything Hugh Jackman's definitely done
and I don't see a version if you're
rebooting the x-men in the MCU where it
would make sense to have Hugh Jackman
unless you do like something like a
cameo or some universe tie-in appearance
something like that will work but I
think being the new flagship Wolverine
just wouldn't make sense for him to be
Wolverine anymore there are so few
circumstances I can imagine that would
outdo Logan as a send-off well I think
that's the biggest thing as he went out
on top now tomorrow there's gonna be a
new video Robert Downey jr. talks if
he'll return inside there's some
conspiracy were like if he returns then
Hugh Jackman will come back and then if
Tobey Maguire come at all the original
cast in all seriousness I have wanted a
Hulk vs. Wolverine movie
for the longest time I've always had a
very specific vision at night of how I
would produce it that's right I said
produce not direct her right or star as
like first you'd get a script and then
you'd find director yeah and then you'd
assemble actors and you know various
other department heads yeah I've always
wanted it to be like a Guillermo del
Toro movie not really what Del Toro's
evolved into as of late something along
the lines of you do Hulk and you get
like one of those giant performers like
an actual 10 football - yeah like
whoever that guy was in the longest yard
but he's in Hope form you put him and
hope make up and you would do like an
r-rated one-off like I have a hard time
actually seeing a genuinely great gritty
version of hope versus Wolverine and the
MCU it to be like a lot of humor and it
probably team up in the end yeah they
can't full-out battle and have one of
them be vanquished because they're right
classic characters well I've always
wanted to see just a one-off completely
different actors in it is enough to be
Mark Ruffalo come on yeah and then you
can have it were like Wolverine is the
bad guy I thought that would be cool
because I think people want to expect
hope but I feel like the interesting
complexity and like the whole dichotomy
of the situation could come in the form
of maybe like I don't know I'm saying I
don't know like I haven't thought about
this like Bruce banners on the run he
has an incident where he Hulk's out and
Wolverine somehow is either maybe still
fresh off the Weapon X program or
something and they basically assign him
to go after Banner I don't know really
fleshed it out that's just been like my
one sentence to sentence [ __ ] it's been
event for the longest time but what I
really wanted was an r-rated type of
very lethal violent version of Hulk vs.
Wolverine I think one of them should
lose and like actually lose in the end
not Freddy vs. Jason lose yeah nobody
really lose yeah just a solid one off I
think that'd be cool and then I think in
the MCU it would be be funny it wouldn't
be a
the awesome artwork we've seen of Hulk
vs. Wolverine basically it would want to
be that it wouldn't be that the thing
image of his face ripping in half that's
not mean like you can't do that it seem
like I'm looking at that image and the
longer I linger on it the more disturbed
by and by it and I think if you did that
in the MCU it just wouldn't fly by well
especially the Disney umbrella not right
now that's the big thing I'm waiting for
and I'm happy that DC is you know
claiming that at the moment but when
Marvel really can start doing one off
side movies that aren't beholden yet to
the main continuity I think there's a
lot of exciting stuff that could happen
I think that's where you would see a
potential Hugh Jackman comeback for some
random take on Wolverine or whatever and
this whole business about Mark Ruffalo
like in talks to possibly return and all
that I was always under the impression
he was still in the MCU I thought it was
just about what's the next project he's
gonna be in for the MCU but I didn't
realize that there was this question at
the air wheel Mark Ruffalo return or not
him like I didn't feel like the
character concluded and all the talk
went to Chris Evans and Robert Danny
leaving I didn't really hear anything
circling around yes I heard about the
Ragnarok to end game arc and that was
like intentional but that didn't ever
sound to me as if Mark Ruffalo could
potentially be done with the Hulk I
never read that way to me it's not like
every character who appears in the
present of endgame is just done with now
and so yeah exactly I feel like if there
was some kind of send-off we would have
known yeah Mark Ruffalo is clearly
enthusiastic too it's not even like he's
getting tired this he seems to just want
to do more of this and also we haven't
seen him do a solo Hulk movie at all
which seems to be a problematic proposal
on the heels of several generations to
come we got incredible home but I would
love to see him just have his own Hulk
movie well Bruce Banner and Hulk since
Ragnarok have both become very funny
characters they have completely switched
and like gone far away from Hulk is
scary you know or tortured yeah they've
really gone far from that and I think
there's a really great Hulk movie
waiting to be made I'm not sure exactly
what it is that they
haven't been able to properly tap into I
think you got to make it a little gritty
I think that's what they're a little
afraid of this by his rage-fueled
character you have to yeah that's the a
turn Aronofsky could weirdly make a
great oh yeah it would be so bleak but
it would be great yeah like it with his
obsession getting lost in this power
yeah
plus you know you get some of the he's
already worked with CGI you think of
those big rock monsters from like Noah
you just apply that theory to Hulk again
Russell Crowe anyway guys hope vs.
Wolverine do you want it to happen
within the MCU would you prefer to be a
little bit more along the lines of what
I'm wishing for leave your thoughts down
below
hey subscriber cosmic wonder subscriber
the real rejects
let's do up for Jason Dolan and Andrew
Hayes we're continuing this theme of
hypothetical meetups between some of our
favorite patrons and this is a scene I
wrote of Andrew and Jason meeting in a
public park are you ready exterior
public park day Andrew Hayes stands with
a camera in hand taking a Dutch angle of
a fountain on the opposite side Jason
Dolan selfie stick attached to a phone
recording himself and one of his many
talented friends for a 12 hour film
festival as Andrews pan clears the
fountain Jason enters frame the to lock
eyes Hayes Dolan making an experimental
short I see this is me bald by the way
yeah making another quirky short film
entry from an obscure film festival how
did you know I have my sources
is that so and have your sources told
you that I'm working on an experimental
short film that's gonna knock your
frickin socks off
impossible apparently your sources don't
know everything Grace Randolph Wow then
again maybe this is all one big reaction
do you ever think of that reaction what
are you talking about Hayes Dolan Dolan
don't you see you played right into my
hands
no one takes a step back on his guard
that's right this is all one try not to
feel like you're being watched Challenge
so you can make whatever little
experimental short film you want to
throw in as many Easter terror
transitions simple
images and philosophical voiceovers as
you like it's still a part of my master
work a beat passes before slowly one
after the other
Jason begins clapping grid spreading
across the space excellent Andrew well
done you were perfect of course I am
what's your point don't you see the
whole time you've been a part of my try
not to break the fourth wall challenge
and since you've just acknowledged your
master plan I win a moment passes who
stare at each other smoldering with
righteous hatred and begrudging respect
and there's only one way to settle this
wait ahead everybody and they both
increase their pledges on patreon
hope you guys enjoyed this hypothetical
situation love you both stay safe and
healthy